do you guys know who Andrew Tate is yeah
do you know who he is yeah do we like
him do we not like him no why not it's a
misogynist can you define misogyny men
are better than women and they're not
wrong have you heard him say men are
better than women though everything he
said is like like what I've actually
heard him once say that women are the
most precious thing in the world what do
you think about that but that's like in
like olden times I know like him
Victorian times when women had to like
stay at home when you're out with a man
would you like him to sort of lead and
maybe pay for you no like 50 50. you
don't want a man to look after you and
provide for you no I want my own job so
since we're all equal and say you're on
a date with a guy and another man comes
and tries to like slap your bum what
would you expect your man to do he
should like stick up for it why now he's
putting himself in the firing line
yeah but what you go why don't you put
yourself in the firing line
but only equal when it comes to buying
dinner